welcome back to the iced coffee hour my
name is chandler david smith and so far
the podcast has made more than 10
million dollars oh come on
you just want to be the biggest number
this year
that is the biggest number of that uh i
think jason oppenheim said like two
million and that would be the second
highest yeah well i'm calling my shot
there we go i don't know a year or two
years
how much
we've made 157 thousand dollars in ad
revenue on the podcast ballpark yeah
that's close so uh thanks so much for
coming on chandler thanks for having me
we had you on what was that like a year
or so ago i think about one year ago it
was about one year ago and things have
changed pretty drastically since january
of last year february when we had you on
it's pretty interesting to see you
because that was the last time we saw
you yeah well in the last time i had
more subscribers and since then you have
just plowed past me you had more
subscribers in the iced coffee hour you
guys were early i was young so where
were you you were like 99 000 right
right sometimes we were both under 100
yeah and then
yeah you guys blew past
tables
well now you're sitting at about like
150 000 subscribers right yeah right
around there and you also have 150
rental units right 60 160 rental units
yeah uh we'll talk about that how you
got it crazy for almost like every
thousand subscribers you get another
unit yeah i've that's been the goal i
need to keep more units than subscribers
so but i want both of them to go up so
if we get you a thousand subscribers
from this you have to buy another unit
100
wow yeah i've got an aplex under
contract so i'd love it if you could get
me 8 000 new subscribers okay so we had
so we had you on originally as i think
meet the real estate investor with and
two tenants
now how many tenants do you have um
that's so hard because we've got 150
units for renting but we've got multiple
like
families a lot of the units i bought
this year were actually bigger so three
bedroom i'd guess we're pushing 300
tenants 310 but really
162 tenants because that's how many
units we have gosh and that's just like
the tip of the iceberg you know you know
the iceberg you'd see
they got storage units on top of that
right yeah yep so 170 something storage
units that's just two
different um storage unit complexes and
this is all located in idaho falls right
yeah idaho yeah well the majority of
it's right within an hour of that area
so why don't you bring the viewers up to
speed on a bit of your backstory how you
got into this for those who have not
seen the first episode because we got an
entirely new audience today so if you
could summarize that in the first few
minutes bring people up to speed on how
you got 300 tenants now yeah so i
started out as a door-to-door salesman
so i couldn't get hired anywhere else
and they said hey if you come move to
california come out in la we can give
you a job it's a hundred percent
commission but we think you could make
you know fifteen thousand dollars
and i was hooked so i picked up my life
left school
went out to go and knock doors and sell
pest control for the three and a half
four months summer
and i got out there and i sucked really
bad
so i didn't sell anything everybody else
was selling well i was work i'd worked
probably a week or two and finally i got
my first sale and then kind of clicked
and so then over the next three three
and a half months i ended up breaking
the company record
and so i sold just shy of 200 000 worth
of pest control contracts so i made 96
000 that first summer
and then i was just in a place where i
needed a place to put it so i came back
and um you know hopped on youtube asked
friends family shopped around and got to
the point where i felt the best about
investing in real estate so at first i
did a hard money loan on a property and
i think the first check you get you know
you put money somewhere and then you get
a check it gets you pumped that got me
really pumped and so then i was really
looking for a rental unit i ended up
buying a condo and then once i got the
condo i started just spending everything
i had in real estate and i've kind of
done that since then so i got a duplex
and a duplex and a four plex and a what
eight plex and a 15 plex and then my
biggest property i've purchased so far
is a 32 unit apartment complex and then
i've just bought a bunch of other four
unit eight unit 11 unit stuff along the
way as well so how old were you at the
time when you first did your that summer
selling pest control so 21 20 the first
time i went out and knocked doors and
sold any college
um i hadn't done any college i had done
a two-year mission for my church up in
canada
so spent a couple years up there and
then came back was super poor and went
out to la
did the pest control thing and then you
continued to sell pest control to have
like a pretty strong income i'm guessing
for the next few years and then all of
that you basically just funneled into
real estate because a lot of the times
like to acquire you know 150 or 160
units at such a young age i mean you
have to have some sort of like like it's
just got to be a strong income right
yeah
it's interesting because looking back
there are lots of things i could have
done better with creative financing and
other options that i've since
used and gotten better relationships
with my credit union and banks and done
all of that but um
the majority of it i've just taken the
money i made and i felt like that was
the the best place for it and so i just
invested it along the way so i've
actually never
used money for any of the down payments
that wasn't mine
i have bought two properties where i've
done partnerships one with my brother
and one with my best friend and those
have both been in the last year so
that's been fun but other than that i've
just come up with the money for the down
payments and put it down and bought
property what do you think about the
real estate market now compared to when
we first talked about a year and a half
ago um
it's such an interesting question
because i think we're all curious when's
it gonna crash
i don't think it's gonna crash and i
think it also depends on which market
you're in i do feel like something has
to give and we know that interest rates
are going up so maybe it'll just slow
down a little bit but in our market
especially out in idaho um we're
struggling because there's not enough
housing like there's legit not enough
properties to rent there's not enough
properties to buy and so i don't see
my market especially slowing down
anytime soon because we are struggling
so much with so so much demand so i
don't know i feel like we're in a great
place the next two to three years and if
i was going to predict a crash i would
have no idea at this point what i would
think would cause it especially in my
market because there is such demand
other than if people just can't pay for
stuff anymore which who knows the
world's weird so
right it's interesting because idaho
falls uniquely has appreciated like
way above the nate like the national
average right like isn't isn't idaho
like the isn't that the number one most
appreciated area
in the u.s i think it was like 30 i
think it was that in phoenix and austin
but i think your area is up like 35
percent
insane doesn't make any sense and it was
because i was so smart and picked it
perfectly
no yeah i got lucky i grew up there and
that's where i bought real estate and
it's been a huge blessing but yeah it's
it's insane i mean i think the last time
we were on here i valued we'd have to go
back but i think i valued my property at
somewhere between 10 and 15 million and
when i've looked at it i think it's more
than 25 million now
and more than you know the majority of
that is just
equity now which surprises me as well
but
i've bought really good deals and we've
increased rents like crazy because the
demand is there so on a lot of my
properties even since i was here last
you know we've been able to bump rents
hundreds of dollars and
since i bought i would say the majority
of my properties rents are more than
double what they were when i took
ownership why so why why is that area
going up so much in particular it seems
like of all the areas you would you
would expect it to be like a coastal
city or like like a booming tech
destination
why
why idaho yeah it's a good question um
so kevin flew out and came and watched
the properties
his thought on it is that it was a bunch
of catch-up appreciation
that it was this stagnant market that
even though it was growing no one really
knew
what they could demand with the growth
and things just had been stagnant for so
long and then
it needed to catch up because it was so
far behind um i think there's some truth
to that i think
it was a market that was just
i don't know comfortable everybody was
comfortable there wasn't a need or it
wasn't normal to expect rents to go up
and now i feel like over the last two
three four years it's become the
standard that you know every year rents
go up substantially it's just part of it
i also think that boise which is the
biggest city in idaho um originally was
a lot smaller and it blew up and i think
a lot of areas like ours in southeastern
idaho have said holy cow look what boise
did and we're following their trajectory
and so you know rents naturally need to
follow i also think inflation hasn't
helped anybody
i think the market as a whole
is going up i i just think it's a
combination of a lot of things and then
finally there are tons of people coming
into idaho i think with covid a lot of
people said hey i actually hate where i
live and i want more space and i want
more land and i want to be close to the
mountains and i want to be away from the
big city and so they came to areas like
idaho falls and pocatello and where i
buy a lot of my real estate but first we
want to thank our sponsor masterworks
alex what are you doing on your phone
nothing much man just buying some art oh
i didn't know you were into art i'm not
into art jack but i am into money with
masterworks i can invest in artwork from
artists like banksy monet or basquiat
for just a fraction of what the
billionaire investors pay and thankfully
i don't need to know much about art
since masterwork specializes in buying
and selling high profile art pieces did
you know that two-thirds of billionaires
hold between 10 and 30 of their
portfolio value in artwork and
considering contemporary art outpaced
the s p 500 by 174
between 1995 and 2020. it's not hard to
understand why getting started with
masterworks is so easy just head to
their website make an account browse
their artwork and then start
diversifying your portfolio with one of
the most stable assets around is anyone
doing it of course man there's over 300
000 investors that have already signed
up and one of their listing by the
famous street artist banksy that
recently went live sold in under three
hours we are always emphasizing just how
important diversifying your portfolio is
so investing in such a stable asset like
art is a no-brainer so if you guys want
to start investing in artwork today
there is a waitlist for masterworks but
if you use the link down below in the
description you can get priority access
and skip the waitlist and start
diversifying your portfolio immediately
and it also supports the channel thank
you so much masterworks for sponsoring
this episode and back to the podcast
how much would you say that is
speculation though because you mentioned
that people are looking at boise and
they're like well
boys is doing that then maybe over here
let's put our money here how much of
that is is just people bidding up
because they expect it's going to be
going up who knows right i mean it's
it's one of those things where every new
property i buy and i go to my management
company i say all right what can we rent
this for and he's like well this is
what the demand is and i mean just to
give you an example on two-bedroom
apartments
i used to be buying properties and
increasing rents on a two-bedroom
apartment we're talking two three years
ago to 700-750 and that was like
wow for 900 square feet on two-bedroom
apartment that's that's high and now i'm
getting 9.50 a thousand dollars for two
bedroom apartments just a couple years
later and so
it's so hard to answer that question
because
it's there there's huge demand there's
huge need how much of it is speculative
i
i don't know people are paying it so
we're gonna keep renting there you know
and it things like that don't change
quickly it's not like something could
happen and then instantly rents are all
gonna drop back down i think even if
something like that did happen it would
happen slowly over time and i also am
the bottom of the market on these
properties like we're talking c
property two bedroom apartments and
they're building a bunch of a brand new
properties with the same square footage
but not much nicer finishes that are
going close to two thousand dollars and
so
if anything has to give i would say it'd
be the more expensive stuff and i just
don't see ours
i'm curious what sustains a two thousand
dollar a month rental payment uh whereas
a few years ago maybe that didn't exist
as much is are there jobs moving to that
location or or is it just a surge demand
from covet has kind of pushed people i
think there are lots of jobs that have
come in and lots of businesses that have
come in but also i'd be lying to you if
i
don't have some concerns of like how are
people going to pay this
um and i think before
i mean
even two three years ago in this market
it would make zero sense to pay two
thousand dollars because you could have
a mortgage for fifteen hundred dollars
and be in a pretty decent home and
that's no longer available and so
i don't know i i really wonder though
because i don't feel like incomes in our
area have gone up to make up for how
much rents and expenses and other things
have gone up you know what's interesting
downtown los angeles you've been there
jack right downtown l.a have you not i'm
not sure
have you been to downtown los angeles
yeah okay it's horrible it's bad in 2005
and six they anticipated that downtown
l.a was going to be like the next major
hub and so every developer was going in
there and they're buying up anything
they could they wanted to build all
these these rentals so they weren't you
know doing so much condos they're doing
a whole bunch of rentals and then when
the market crashed they had all these
half finished projects but they finished
them but what ended up happening is that
all the rents in that area collapsed
because they were so they were trying to
build because there was so much demand
and then it just
wiped away when that happened and i
remember i think it was between 2011 and
like 2015 or 16 so like seven years
there where rents probably dropped like
50 percent and i remember these
buildings that they would get people in
because they didn't want to show that
they're renting them at like 50 off so
they would say if you move in we'll give
you like six months of free rent we'll
give you the first like three to six
months free depending on how long of a
lease you sell at what price
just move in anybody move in that was
just the newer places or all of it
almost all of it because yeah because
the the older places couldn't compete
with like a brand new building that was
just finished and like six months of
free rent to move in here
uh now i mean obviously for the people
that held through that they're doing
just fine and downtown ola is really
recovered but yeah those seven years
were really tough for downtown yeah and
even now they're still kind of suffering
to a certain extent yeah well in seeing
all the new construction that's going on
in my area i'd be lying if i didn't say
that it concerns me a little bit with
how much they're building because it's
it's crazy but when you go and you know
go and sit down the city council
meetings and hear what they're talking
about they're very concerned that we
just don't have the housing that's
needed and
for me personally even though it might
affect my rents like my rents have to
come down i've gotten away where i'm
okay with that but there's also a part
of me that like i don't want my
community to
get to the point where there isn't
somewhat affordable housing does that
make sense like as a landlord i want to
make a premium i want to make good money
but also i think
if new construction does level it out so
that it's not increasing at such a crazy
rate i'm not going to be super bummed
about that yeah
i just get so worried when i see an area
and every area like even las vegas is up
i think it's 25 percent year over year
it's like 26 which is crazy but i get
worried when it's that much in a year
i'm like what's changed the only thing
that i could pinpoint that's really
changed a lot of people moving from
california new york high tax states here
which i think it accounts for a decent
amount and i don't think those people
are moving back
but other than that i worry about that
because there's so much land here to
build more homes and that right now is
just a supply constraint so they just
can't bring in enough material but when
they can i'm like how could they not
build more homes yeah it it definitely
i'm the same way it's like it doesn't
register it doesn't make sense so
something has to give
and i just hope it's not to the point
where
it's a bad thing for me but
[Laughter]
but
and again that's why it's been nice that
i've bought right because
you know we're buying aggressively but
also we're being smart with it where
even if rents dropped 50 which i don't
think they ever could but we're still
going to be making money not nearly as
much money but i think a lot of people
where they go wrong as they're going in
and they're investing tons of money and
their return is small and the only real
estate they own is at that premium and
then i mean so situations i have to
believe that hurt so i'm curious 162
units why not at that point just be like
you know what uh things are going really
well right now let me let me take some
of the money uh that i'm making from
this and put it somewhere else like why
don't i invest in stocks do index funds
maybe a different location
why why keep going
i think
for me
it ties back to why i keep going at all
right
like and and i'm sure you're in a
similar situation you've got the money
to have the lifestyle that i'm sure you
wanted
and maybe there's more there's always
more um but
for me i'm not passionate about other
things i think that it would diversify
my situation it would probably eliminate
a little more risk because i'm very
heavy
heavily invested in idaho in a in a
specific area and so i personally want
to buy more real estate nationwide and i
think that's the next step for me but i
really love buying real estate i really
love the model i love the tax advantages
i love the returns um it's something i'm
passionate about and so i don't as much
as i try to get into the other realms i
just don't enjoy it like i do real
estate have you have you tried yeah yeah
i mean i've got money in crypto i've
thrown some money in you know stocks and
it just maybe i need to put more money
in but it's like oh yeah like we gotta
even best case scenario and i haven't
gotten crazy but it's like okay best
case you get a what 10 to 20 return
and you just have uh that little return
on your money that is there i don't know
it doesn't get me pumped but with real
estate it's like man i see the check
coming in every month i know that not
only am i getting that check but with
cost segregation i'm getting
depreciation i can use against all of my
other businesses so i'm not paying tax
and all these properties are exploding
in value the cash flow is increasing
you're getting the principal pay down
like it just it's fun it's exciting it's
cool and i don't like in my heart of
hearts i don't believe i found another
investment that the risk versus reward
makes it worth it putting it there i
just truly believe this is the best way
to invest all right but first we want to
thank our sponsor morningbrew man i'm so
tired i could definitely use some
morning brew right now me too alex there
is nothing i love more than learning and
keeping up to date with the latest
trends first thing in the morning from a
cup of coffee no alex from morningbrew
morningbrew is a company that makes the
best daily newsletter that keeps me up
to date with all the business news that
i used to miss out on i read
morningbrew's email newsletter every
single day now and i can honestly say
that i love how easy they make it to
keep up with today's current events i
found morning brews daily newsletter
while i was uh
doing work and i saw their article on
why taylor swift's newest album was
scaring record companies and now
morningbrew even has a youtube channel i
found this really cool video of them
going into detail about how the chip
shortage is affecting our economy and
how tech companies might have to invent
new semiconductor infrastructures to
keep up with today's demand and that's
just one of many fascinating and
entertaining stories morning brews
youtube channel has to offer so go
subscribe to morningbrews youtube
channel if you're interested in business
finance or tech we have links down below
in the description thank you so much
morningbrew and back to the podcast i
think it'd be interesting to talk about
some numbers so you said you owned about
10 million dollars in assets in real
estate last year how much money do you
think you made just in appreciation
alone from that and then right now what
are your numbers as far as like gross
rental income and then maybe just like
the whole big picture yeah so um
it's a tricky question
the easiest way to answer it would be i
owned 10 million and i think average
appreciation was what 25 30 in our
market so
i'm
the the difference with my properties
though is
a lot of them we bought with huge value
adds so for example
the 32 unit the 15 unit the 11 unit a
lot of these that i've bought in the
last
year year and a half
um when we bought them the rents were
super low and we've literally doubled
the rents on those properties
and
the value on those is determined by the
rents and so buying a deal that
you know already had value added if the
market didn't go up
but it has
it's so hard to do the the quick math
but i'd guess
i don't know probably 5 million
[Music]
to 8 million somewhere in there of just
like just appreciation yeah added value
added value um and maybe that's a
stretch but it's been
a massive chunk because of forced
appreciation and
just what's happened when it comes to um
gross rents
i believe we in the last video were over
a hundred thousand
um per month
and i knew you were going to ask me this
so i just did the math on the new
properties we've purchased and some of
the increases and i think we've added an
additional 50 to 60 000 per month since
i was here last
so i think we're gross between 150 and
160 000 every month then you've got
mortgage and expenses right do you have
any idea what the net is on that
yeah how much how much do you personally
claim on your tax return everything
well so here's the
here's the tricky thing about the
question i'm sure it feels like i'm
skirting it but
i've bought close to 50 units since we
were on here last time and a storage
unit complex every one of those has been
value add properties where for instance
the 11 unit we bought six months ago
we've had to increase the rents on that
property from an average of 450
up to 8.50
and some of those leases have already
expired and we've increased rents some
of them haven't and so every month it
evolves does that make sense so i know
where it should be
after having owned the property for a
year but also i've got so much new real
estate that's in this sure
progression of getting rents to where
they need to be so
huh how much debt do you have um
i think
13 to 14 million unless i checked
math so
so that's about 20 equity per unit or
per bill per
structure
is it give or take 15 percent equity i
mean i think because of all the equity
we've added i mean i i valued the real
estate about 25 million and we owe
13 million on it so
we've kind of reached a point even with
the new purchases where there's more
equity in the properties than debt i'm
curious do storage facilities make more
money than the real estate um
it just depends on the property it's
just the same though okay you know how
much value can you add to them the
storage units are another one
when finding properties and everyone
says oh the market's so hard it's hard
to find good properties the best
properties are when you run into people
that owned the properties for 30 40 50
years
and they get the rents they increase
them the first 10 20 years they own them
and then they're like dude i've got the
property paid off it's cash flowing like
crazy
and they don't do anything with the
rents and so both of our storage unit
complexes were in that scenario where
literally the one that i just bought it
was grossing like 6 000 a month and now
i've got it grossing 11 000
[Music]
11 500 and so
when you say which one makes more it's
like well that was a freaking killer
deal so it made a ton
um but they both do well they have pros
and cons i never have to deal with
evictions i never have to deal with
super upset tenants like if people are
upset with storage units they just move
their stuff or they leave it and you
figure it out it's not like their home
there's not as much passion behind it
and i really like that part about
storage units yeah what would make a
great business i just came up with this
by the way so someone could take this
here's my genius idea okay you were
mentioning these owners who own the
place for like 30 40 years they don't do
anything with the rent they don't need
to because they don't only get on it
everything's profits they're like uh
what do i care an extra 10 15
how great would it be if someone came in
there and said hey i'll turn this place
around for you i'm going to manage it
you still own it
but i'll take
40 of the profit above what you're
currently making for the next
10 years or something like that that
would be a great business without
needing to go in and buy the building
yourself yeah i think it totally would i
also think that a lot of these old
owners
are very very anti being approached with
anything because they're just content
and that's the interesting thing is it's
not like
i think a lot of times when people hear
a story like that they think it's like
me going to the old grandma and talking
her into selling me her house 200 000
below what it's worth it's very
different because a lot of these people
they're smart they're just old and
they're tapped out and so when you build
a relationship with them they'll look me
in the eye and say look i know rents
need to go way up i just haven't want to
deal with a headache i just don't want
to do it i want to sell it and so i want
you to pay a premium and when you show
them you know look you know you probably
bought this property getting an 8 9 10
cap back then i'm buying it at a five
cap all right with where your current
rents are so i can't go any lower i'd be
losing money when i took ownership now
i'm gonna bump it but it just it doesn't
make sense and that argument where
they're leaving a little bit so you can
get a return with where the rents are at
it makes sense to them and it's fair
because they don't have to do the work
they don't have to deal with it they've
made tons of money on it and they're
fine to say all right i know you're
getting a killer deal i don't want to
deal with it though go crazy
so i don't know how open they would be
to
you know letting someone come in and
going through the stress maybe i'm wrong
though i'm sure some would but does that
make sense it does that makes sense a
lot uh i am curious though before we
move on what do you do with the storage
units where they just leave it
um
there's a long process you know how you
see like the auctions after all of that
you want the honest answer probably yeah
i do i have no idea i haven't dealt with
it my management company does
and we know it's a long process
i don't deal with it do they auction off
the the units um i think that you have
to like
this is to what i think okay they think
you have to post it put something on
their door wait a certain amount of time
and then if they don't do it you have to
go through the auction process because i
think
they don't want to allow the owner to
have the ability to just go and take
stuff out and get rid of it yeah and so
i think there's a whole thing with that
we haven't really had issues though um
at least that i know of my big thing is
look at the key indicators and i know
those properties i needed the gross
rents to a certain amount and we went
past that certain amount as long as it's
that every month i'm not asking
questions i'm good yeah you know what
alex weren't we looking into buying a
storage unit what happened to that what
yeah we were so i did send you some over
and uh i don't think you looked at them
no i didn't how much were they um they
actually vary so they
they you look at the front of the
storage unit and depending on what you
can see is actually like the estimated
value like if you open it and you see a
bunch of like instruments obviously
people are going to bid that thing up
but if you open it you see a bunch of
boxes old clothes um i mean it could go
for
you know just like a hundred bucks like
it's just so dependent on what you see
as soon as you open the unit how easy is
it to bid i want to i want to buy one
that would be so fun for this to family
yeah that would be so fun yeah i mean
here's the thing i would use it for
content on one channel something if it's
good if we go in there and there's like
valuables if it's worth more than i paid
it's going to be a main channel video if
it loses money
then i'm like all right it's the family
so either way so either way you're
monetizing the content is what you're
using no way yeah there's no way i would
waste that otherwise right and if it's
if it's you know bad i'm gonna post an
instagram and be like hey maybe we could
do like a meet and greet just like
comments people take our trash yes but
that's the thing
but but but in order to like just come
by you have to take something with five
pounds that's what you did that's what
happened when we cleaned out your old
house graham in uh in l.a yeah yeah you
told jack to clean it out and uh jack
took the stuff that he wanted and then
we posted on instagram hey you can come
meet jack and i but
you have to take one piece of
whatever it is it worked for the most
part that was so sad for me by the way
it was yeah it really was i you told me
not to throw out your fake plants and i
threw them out why really because i
didn't i just you know what's funny i
didn't even remember them until you
mentioned them
and now i run through all the memories i
know where i got those fake plants there
was a there was a house that that i had
sold
and the owner bought those to stage yeah
and then no i'm upset i threw those out
because now i have an obsession with
fake plants they're really nice this
this was from his house these guys right
here those are cool yeah i will say you
should have kept the houseplants and put
them in your house because
it definitely needs a feminine touch
okay so we all say it's a frat house is
it is it a friend it's bad
yeah it's very 100 it's a fraction
it's it definitely looks like a single
dude lives there for sure but not only a
single dude like a single college
oh god oh no give you guys a visual okay
hold on you got to listen to this i'm
going to run this through my mind close
the visual yeah close your eyes okay you
walk into this place okay
from the outside it looks like a nice
like respect
the first thing you see
is a money rug a hundred dollar bill is
a money rug with like 50 pairs of shoes
scattered around the entrance it's funny
we have a shoe rack that you put your
shoes on and it's always empty and all
of the shoes are just scattered around
so imagine he never has any shoes you
have to step around like 50 pairs of
shoes and then to the left you see
fluorescent lights
i was gonna add a ceiling pin all those
up you just i was like
yes
like we're talking about like the the
home depot sort of fluorescent tubes
that you see that like would be in a
medical office industrial stuff
industrial stuff you see hanging from
the ceiling with wires hanging down
below that is a ping pong table with
great lighting great lighting
uh it's supposed to be a living room
because there's like a fireplace there
no other furniture besides the ping pong
table you walk through that is an empty
room with nothing in it there's just a
light dangling from the ceiling then you
go into the kitchen there's a foosball
table in there okay a foosball table
then you can walk to the kitchen and
there's one little thing for plants but
the table is like wrongly proportioned
for that size
the kitchen there's a whole bunch of
stuff scattered around the kitchen a
whole bunch of bananas so you have a lot
of bananas in your kitchen oh we go
through about 30 bananas yeah and then
the living room is the the only part
that bears some resemblance of of being
an adult because you have a an old
person's picture that looks like you got
it from your grandparents did uh you did
okay
hung on the wall but below that you have
like a bright blue suede couch
got it from alex that you got from alex
it doesn't match anything else in the
house i like the contrast and the
upstairs like just a mattress on the
face it's been so descriptive yeah i was
there yesterday but i do think
like hearing you walk me through it i'm
remembering it worse than it actually
was worse than it was no i'm remembering
it oh
yeah i think like
you know what i mean it was yeah it's
not that bad it's not a single guy but
yeah it could use a loving woman's touch
no no yeah i get it like jack i think a
little bit of planning would go along
that house goes so well and i guarantee
someone watching this is a designer who
would just meet you and help you out
it's just weird for me because to me i
walk into that house and i'm just like
this is the most incredible house i have
literally built this house exactly how i
wanted it you know i haven't
what because my guess is with all those
other guys living there they're paying
you rent right yeah
a little bit that's why it's great yeah
no that helps out exactly it's a good
investment so
you know it's a fantastic investment and
also
it's just the perfect house we oriented
that house exactly i got the comfiest
couch i got a tv we have a foosball
table and a ping pong table we put in
these incredible lights it's just you
know amazing reminds me uh
in uh like after my friends graduated
high school you know i'd go to a few
like friends of friends houses and and
it was by usc so sometimes like their
dad would go and like buy them a house
or something around campus as an
investment and the kids would live there
and they could sell the house later
reminds me of those houses that like you
know your dad gets you a house and you
just move in on your own oh you need
basically a frat house is what you're
saying basically a frat house jack i'm
just thinking you could make this place
so nice really like really nice to the
point where like something's so nice
already
but i'm but i'm saying jack at some
point you're gonna have you're gonna
have a lot of people going over to your
house right yeah and you want them to
walk in and feel like you know wow this
is where this is where jack lives like
have you brought a date there yet
uh yeah it's a couple yeah but hasn't
you brought a second date back oh i felt
fantastic i was like wow like they must
really
i think this is something spectacular
right
they didn't work but we'll see why we'll
see it could be the shoes could be a
myriad
yeah
but anyways that's that's my girl will
love it you think so yeah i do
i think the right guy
i think guys are the ones that
appreciate that house but not but not
only just guys uh i like i like voice
itself yeah i would say guys under 23.
i'm 23. i'm not under 23. so yeah so hey
i just noticed you're wearing an active
shirt for me i wore this on purpose i'm
flattered yeah so this is active as his
uh his door-to-door sales business the
pest control thing so yeah you gave it
to me thanks so much for it thanks for
wearing it one thing i wanted to bring
up was after we had you on the podcast
the first time you knew i wanted to get
into rental real estate and we both had
a mutual friend jack dougherty who was
17 at the time
dougherty dougherty
and you basically led him to a perfect
like a duplex right bitter about that
you are just because it was a great deal
yeah he told me fantastic i was hoping
for drama i'm bitter about that
no he's awesome man i'm bumped no he's
stoked on the deal and
then i reached out to you with another
killer deal yes that has since gone up
in value by a ton it hurts so much and
you didn't buy it the issue was you
brought it up to me on like a friday and
you're like you have to get everything
situated it was it was like uh gotta act
now because it was yeah and i just
wasn't ready for that nor did i think it
was the deal
it was just a duplex but um rents were
low it was a really good deal and it was
really clean this was like a b property
and i'm usually a c plus guy but this
was like it was quality quality duplex
who bought it um i flipped it to one of
my sales reps
okay yeah we've got
all of my
um
do you remember i want to say like or
something was it two something what was
it duplex it was like 250.
what was your renting for
um it was two-bedroom both of them
upstairs and downstairs i'm guessing
now it's probably like 900 uh or 950 up
900 down something like that 1800 a
month with 250.
it's a good deal you have to fix it up
no it was like clean no it was nice it
just again it was one of those older
couple owned it they'd renovated it kept
it nice i was a wimp yeah i just i just
didn't no i i remember it was stressful
because you hadn't bought one and i'm
like we gotta do it i've never bought a
property before but now i have and now
it's like oh man i can get all my stuff
ready like that but yeah that was a that
was an incredible deal okay well i'll
keep my eyes open there wasn't enough
room for a ping pong table that's right
you said there's a man
pool table in the front of the house
yeah you got a soul you got a money
picture when you walk in i'll remember
that next time i'll go hit walmart and
put up a bunch of string lights yeah
perfect yeah
oh by the way one thing i forgot to
mention about your place
you just remind me
i love how there's like a gym set in the
garage like like for the you got like a
bench
with like the weights i just wanted to
add that in there it's yeah it's like a
really sketchy gem set i already shared
the surprise of your new vehicular
purchase uh yeah so
houston not on the podcast but the last
episode we uh uploaded was with houston
and graham was like jack you got to buy
a lotus you got to buy like these fancy
cars and i said no i want a mazda miata
the following night lucky from
automotive life watching the podcast no
so he actually he sent me a listing to
uh mazda miata on facebook marketplace
and then later that night he just so
happened to watch the podcast no pure
coincidence yeah wow and he sent sent it
to me i checked it out i liked it the
following day we went and actually saw
in person lucky came with me being the
great guy he is he said it checks out i
bought it 4 100. let's go wow i thought
he'd listen to us daniel's trying to hey
man i heard you want a miata i found no
destiny yeah manual transmission
convertible i was just going to say that
car really matches your vibe in that
garage looks good you think so
yeah the weight rack and everything
don't you think it fits with the dents
yeah
yeah all right i i till jack an s 2 000.
it's so expensive
they are expensive i love those cars i
think over over the next 10 years those
cars are going to go up way more in
value because i think the miata is good
though i like them thanks graham i think
for 4100 you're not going to go wrong i
already bought it under market value so
i already made some money on it so
that's good yeah and i'll fix it up a
little bit make it nice value add yeah
exactly value ads rent it out yeah so
we'll see turo
smart i want you to go i want you to
pick up a date in that car and vlog it
oh she'd love it
i think i don't know i've never thought
of this but onturo do they have like
super super cheap like five dollars for
the day no the issue is well you can
list it for whatever price you want but
i think turo takes about 30 percent and
also
um
your car has to be newer than like 2 000
something that makes sense my car is
definitely 22 years old 23 whatever yeah
you're out of luck yeah
i think it'd be kind of interesting to
talk a little bit about your sales okay
as well because you said you have 500
people like 500 sales reps right yeah uh
is that like active sales reps or are
those like in and out yeah so the way
that it works is
every year we recruit for eight months
of the year so we have our core leaders
that come back year after year after
year and we get more leaders after they
prove themselves by coming out and
knocking and doing well and then during
that time period we're hiring
training and training our leaders
preparing them for the summer so when
the summer gets here the reason for that
is a lot of the people that work for us
are in school so the summer gets here
and they all disperse throughout the
country
we set them up with apartments we have
trainings every morning we have leaders
that work with us for years that go and
give them the training and so they're
just all over the place and they show up
and we train them get them proper
licensing give them everything they need
and then cut them loose on the doors so
that 500 sales reps every year it kind
of grows we'll see where we end up this
year for my salesforce but this last
year we were actually ended up just a
little shy of 500 this year so we should
be well over 500 this upcoming year and
those guys did over 27 million in sales
in the four month summer this last
summer now it's interesting to me
because with a real estate real estate
portfolio of like 20 some million
dollars you would think that being like
a part of corporate pest control selling
would not be worth your time
yeah it must bring in a decent amount of
money if you're still balancing that
with your youtube channel and also your
you know 160 doors of rental real estate
yeah i mean the reality is that's been
my cash cow forever and we're paid
commission i'm paid commission even as a
leader so the more that i
produce the more that my sales force
produces the more we make like just like
any business and we've gotten it to the
point where we can scale really quickly
and the youtube channels helped with
that and i think the other thing that's
really helped my sales force scale and
one of the things that keeps me tied to
it is my passion for what we provide for
not only our customers with our pest
control service but i really
care and love what we provide for the
sales reps because a lot of times we've
got these college kids that have no idea
what they're going to do with their
lives they're like me where it's like i
can't get accepted for other jobs i
don't know what i want to do maybe i'll
go home and stay in my parents basement
or you know what what should i do
and if they find us they're around a
bunch of driven people that go and teach
them how to sell teach them how to work
hard help them go out and make
extraordinary money and then when they
get back during that eight months we
have a group
for all of our reps that is our real
estate group so we do
a call every other week
and it's almost like completely free
consulting for our people and it's just
one of those things i'm really
passionate about because now we can
provide a way for them to go and make
great money and then we can provide a
way for them to come home and show them
how to invest i feel like that should be
mandatory after high school like
everyone should be doing that for one
year i doing sales yes door-to-door
sales i agree everybody just give a year
of that well and here's why because
you know better than anyone i think
anyone that's successful they've had
huge failures they've had to push
through the rejection they've had to
push through
all of those struggles and there is no
better refiners fire than going and
having people tell you no for you know
10 hours a day for four months straight
you deal with tons of rejection you
figure out how to
deflate confrontation to push through
objections to deal with feeling like
crap because everyone's telling you no
and find a way to be positive to be
upbeat to hit the next door and treat it
like a fresh door like that it breaks
your brain to get it to function in a
way that you can handle rejection that
you can stay positive that you can work
hard that you can communicate with
people and so the skill set that reps
come out of
like
what better way to learn how to run a
business or how to go through higher
education or how to do anything it just
really sets you up to do whatever after
that i did door knocking briefly
probably i spent maybe two months doing
door knocking it was terrible so i look
back at that
have you seen the video where i took
kevin out i did we should take you out
we should do you're not pushing yours
no i'm not i'm very timid though like to
walk up to is because i know like i
don't like when people knock on my door
so i think i put myself in that
situation be like i don't want
inconveniences
i'm just going to knock in there do you
want to sell your house i used to get
this so i would go up there and uh i i
was so cringy oh man it's all i'd spent
all night the night before printing out
like a hundred packages of sales comps
in every area
and uh and i targeted mar vista so
because like santa monica was really
competitive venice was like really
competitive mar vista was more like
families but i didn't do enough research
into that area because you're supposed
to look at like the turnover ratio santa
monica venice is a big turnover ratio
that uh mar vista did not so like a lot
of the people who lived there lived
there for like 50 60 years didn't move
my fault for not doing the research but
i'd print out the sales cops just i i
had a whole map of the area and i just
highlight every block that i went down
and i wanted to hit the whole area and
then i calculated like okay it'll take
me about two months to hit every single
house and then i could do it again
and uh it was really bad did you get a
single
like client out of that no
no i said like two three no no i didn't
uh
no i didn't i got really close um
there there was one or two in particular
where the people let me in the house are
thinking they're like you know we might
sell if you want to take a look through
the house if you might have a client so
i'd go through the house i get their
info nothing ever came from it
um
some people were really rude like they
would open up and you'd see like the the
screen so you couldn't see them what do
you want
no no we're not in australia they just
slam the door the worst were the dogs
though when you would knock
and you would hear the person yelling at
the dog to be crying god you try to talk
over the door yeah yeah they'd open the
thing and like barely any of the dogs go
crazy
what do you want like oh i just want to
give you sales comps
you could leave it at the door i just
leave it it was horrible but yeah i did
it two months and i thought to myself i
would rather quit real estate
than ever door knock again because
either as i was quitting or i'm not door
knocking yeah i just figured i'm not
gonna door knock it is the most
uncomfortable job you can ever do i
think that's why i love it so much i
mean i've been doing it for 12 years and
i'll still go out for a couple weeks and
go and shadow just so i stay fresh and
because i want to stay good at it and
every time like this summer when i go
out you get the jitters you're just like
oh this is so uncomfortable i don't wow
yeah you get you get the jitters yeah
well the other thing you can do nervous
this sounds really
arrogant but that's why i like it is it
keeps you super humble is the first door
they open and they're like you have to
get out of here and they slam the door
like you don't know who i am you don't
know what i've done like i'm a good guy
but it uh it's fun it's good stuff yeah
it's it's incredible because yeah i
remember like my anxiety would keep
getting worse the closer i got to that
area and then i'd park the car and i
kind of like
do i really want to do this today i'm
like if i just do one door let me just
knock in the store and just walking up
to the house is like your heart starts
beating faster and faster and faster and
sometimes your mouth would go dry and
you would knock and be like you might
instantly go blank you forget what you
have to say
and they'll open the door and you're
like
uh
here you go
just leave that's terrible
jack i'd love to see you do that oh god
i am so bad at that as far as
confronting people i am just terrible
and as far as
you want pest control
i think it's like it's uh
inconveniencing people i try so hard to
never inconvenience someone because it's
just such an awkward thing because i'm
aware i'm inconveniencing them right and
they know what i like that i know that
as well so i just try to stay away from
stuff like that but i remember back in
high school i used to have to collect
money for these fundraisers for the
track team and i'd have to go like door
knocking and i'm not even providing like
any value at that point i'm just like yo
can i have some money to like say you
sponsor me so i can run laps for you and
that was like very uncomfortable for me
yeah so you know what i'd love to do
though that i thought uh who do who did
this the guy from appsumo um
am i blanking on his name alex you know
the guy appsumo yeah is it noah kagan
yes
he went door to door and asked people
what they did for a living
i thought that was a great idea and i
thought that would do so well if we
could even go through this community and
just ask what people do for a living
that would be cool because it's easy as
a neighbor be like i'm a neighbor what
do you do for a living you have to ask
to film them well here's
no you you don't have to i've done a lot
of filming on the doors for yeah just
because one tons of interesting stuff
happens and i've done lots of videos
with it you just film before and then
you ask them after you're like okay is
it okay if we use it
by the way we've been recording this
entire thing and you use this yep
and then you can
yeah i've had a couple
that that's the thing that's funny about
knocking doors it's super uncomfortable
and the craziest stuff happens like the
stories i could tell you man of just
what's the craziest thing that comes to
mind very uncomfortable situations
people opening the door butt naked just
to see how you'll respond
that's super funny and they just act
like nothing's going on because they
think it's funny no
as long as they're not threatening if
they did that to me when i was doing
knocking i think it would be i'd be kind
of humored by it yeah well you never
know whether you should just do your
pitch and pretend like nothing's
happening or be like
this is funny
do you do you train people how to handle
situation you have to right how do you
get well so if someone answers without
any clothes i mean there's not a
training on the no close guy but there's
a there's a chorus on it somewhere
what's that what's the go-to tactic i
the times it's happened to me
i just
roll through it and do the pitch right
like keep good eye contact did you ever
sell pest control to someone who is
i've sold some crazy situations like
times where they're like going at it
with their spouse just like at each
other's throat and the husband's like
you will not buy this and she's like
i'll buy it if i ever want to and you're
just like okay just sign here i'm gonna
go with it
just
wild stuff
yeah we've had um
we actually had a video i've thought
about putting this on my channel but i
don't know the legal implications yet
but recently we had a guy pull a gun on
our sales rep and pointed at him out in
the street so he came out of his house
out on the street and pointed at our rep
and said get out of my neighborhood when
it's a legal neighborhood to knock in
this last year we had a cop that went up
our guy's just pitching the cop tells
the guy to come down and it was one of
our better sales reps and so he just
said look i've got all the proper
licensing i know i'm allowed to be here
that was actually a customer she wanted
to sign up with me so he let me get
about my day like i'm not doing anything
wrong here's my license he's like no and
he's like he shouldn't have said this we
train him not to but the kid said could
you get the real cops because they know
this is my license guy grabs him throws
him down handcuffs him asked where his
car is goes and searches his car brings
him in and the kid has to spend the
night in jail next day they drop all the
charges and it just disappears it's just
an absolute joke so just
wild and these are extremes but when
you've got hundreds and hundreds of jobs
why not have them wear like a body cam
or something like could you do that you
could but
500 sales reps 500 body cams people
wouldn't turn it on like i
i don't know i don't think the pros
cause it's so rare that stuff happens
yeah and now that there are so many ring
cameras usually if stuff does get happen
you can go and find one of the neighbors
that has a ring camera that caught it
and so yeah but they wouldn't get the
audio on that though yeah right if you
recorded every single single interaction
that your reps had with clients
it would actually make some pretty
incredible youtube and also i'm sure
would also teach your other rep like
perhaps how to sell yeah or what not to
do and just like unique situations that
come up because i know that people on
youtube they're like uber drivers and
they set up dash cams and they flip them
around those youtube videos go viral
with like interact like interesting
interactions with like you know uber
customers 100 well even this last year
when i was out shadowing i had a guy
come out and just cuss me out for no
reason i was just good
and uh james was in the car recording
stuff because we record it for trainings
and for youtube and for all of that and
uh
yeah it's people love that everybody
yeah they love seeing people lose their
shiz and be jerks so to be clear you did
you have not sold to someone who
answered naked for their record i have
not sold them no okay
so maybe it's safe to say that if they
they answer without their clothes
statistically just go to the next store
probably that's probably what the
training should be
but that's not as exciting do you notice
these incidents happen more with like uh
like does it matter if it's male or
female or like uh have you noticed a
difference in terms of like
if
we'll keep going
okay don't keep going in terms of his
sales right and if it's female how do i
sign up for those
what are you saying i'm just saying has
he noticed anything where it's like it
happens
yeah no no
it happens more with like if female
sales people versus mail if they end up
getting more sales or like that that's
what i'm not asking the questions i want
to ask but i just was uncomfortable
asking it though so as far as yeah
as far as like which
are better yeah yeah so um between that
or like having incidents of like being
brought in and then
um
i think with our female reps obviously
they're more careful like
and i think a lot of times
girls are more
just because i think unfortunately
they've had to deal with more
crap like that like they're
just naturally that happens more and so
i think a lot of our female reps know to
not ever go inside a home unless they're
like 100 confidence it's a safe
situation yeah um with our female reps
as well usually they'll stay to where
they're on the same street as another
rep do they carry anything on them like
a pepper spray or like something um some
do most don't
but because
we're making it sound bad it doesn't
happen that often it happens more than
an average job obviously but it's a rare
occurrence it is like a lot of people
could go their entire
career
you won't go your entire career without
having someone like lose their shiz on
you and freak out and cuss you out and
say they're gonna call the cops and call
the cops like they're just crazy people
so that happens frequently but when it
comes to
those situations it's not like those
happen a ton
got it i think we should move on to uh
we talk about the evil landlord yeah oh
boy controversy yeah so you uh you know
every everybody at some point is a bit
of a bit of a controversy
yours just recently happened somebody
called you an evil landlord yeah for a
video that kevin posted on his channel
yeah you had a video where you can i
don't know if we call it confronted you
questioned a tenant who you were
evicting yeah kevin reacted to that and
broke down the situation i was like
here's what you did here's what they did
here's what what's what's the situation
he broke it down very nicely
that was put on tick tock
and got a lot of traction and then
people are now going after you for for
being a landlord essentially yeah so i
ended up reposting the whole video
because of
after kevin posted it i just kind of
wanted to like be able to show
everything because even though kevin is
a friend and i feel like he gave a good
evaluation of it people can still skew
from a shorter video so i posted the
long form video so people could see
because i feel like
the whole video
paints a very fair picture of a very
very bad tenant
me because this was a good probably
three years ago when we had the actual
situation happen so i was still a newer
landlord i still made tons of mistakes i
shouldn't have made um
but i feel like i was in the right on
everything it was a really bad tenant
there were drugs there was
they were stealing electricity from up
above they destroyed the property they
were causing tons of issues for the
upstairs tenants it was a really bad
situation um so yeah it's when tick tock
came out i have someone that repurposes
all of my content and they repurpose the
tick tock content from the long form it
did really well on take talk and then
i've gotten blasted by one video in
particular that there
there's this part of the dark web i had
no idea about of people that truly
believe
landlords shouldn't exist like all
housing should be
equal fair like
just lots of views that obviously i
disagree with
but then they're like if you're a
landlord you're satan and you're
it's bad and
yeah they came at me hard and it was
disappointing to uh experience that
because i feel like the people that
follow my channel and the majority of my
videos i don't get that many negative
comments because i'm just teaching
people how to invest in real estate and
the last thing i'll say and then we can
see what questions you have about it but
looking back
even though i got a ton of views to make
up for the 15 000 renovation in the
months of rent that i lost which
financially ended up being beneficial
if i could go back i don't think i would
have let kevin post it or have posted
the video
only reason for it i think i did
everything right legally fair for the
tenant um i just even though i got their
permission to air it in everything i
don't know that i should have aired out
that like i don't know that i want to
connect myself to like taking someone
that's on drugs in a bad situation
and
being the one to put that on the
internet does that make sense it does so
so what were the main concerns that
people had with your video and just to
be clear the video was you just having a
conversation with your ex-tenant right
as you're going through the process of
an eviction with them uh because they
were like yeah on drugs and stuff like
that so what was the main like
controversy with that were they they
were not on on drugs at the time you
filmed right it seemed like they were
maybe me i mean i can't seem like they
were or deny i know that they had
multiple other drug charges and it did
seem like halfway through the interview
like we were having a reasonable
conversation and then something i saw
and the girlfriend
like it was like she knew something hit
and she got out of there and you can see
in the video they talk about she said
like yeah we've boxed a couple times and
i'm like
what like meant that they had fought
with each other and
it had gotten physical and it just was a
really bad okay but yeah the reason we
knew that there were drugs involved is
because of complaints from upstairs and
charges that had happened while we're
going through
the process of trying to get this tenant
out like
does that make sense it does it was just
it was a bad situation but to answer
your question
um
the only thing that i think i got heat
for and this wasn't the majority of the
heat but just the fact that i aired that
right that was the monetize something
yeah someone else was struggling that
was the one thing at my core that i'm
like
they probably have a little bit of a leg
to stand on there even though it was so
bad and the big reason i put it out
there is one i was so frustrated because
when you have a tenant do this there's
no way you can get that money back
literally like when you have a tenant
that's a deadbeat that doesn't pay
even if you get the courts to say yeah
you can evict them and they owe this
money you'll never see that money like
it is impossible to get it out of
someone that is in that situation and so
it just is really frustrating then you
go in and see not only did you not pay
rent but now i've got a 15 000
renovation so that's why i justified in
my head and obviously if i'd felt good
about it at the beginning i probably
would have posted on my own but i didn't
post it and then kevin saw it and he's
like dude we gotta post this
he's always going to that
yeah so
um the other stuff though
no ground whatsoever because the other
complaint is just a general landlord in
general like every landlord is satan the
other complaint was just like they said
no the tenant said they weren't stealing
electricity when i was interviewing them
i was like hey did you still electrician
they're like no the upstairs tenant said
we could i'm like dude we lost the
upstairs tenant because they were so
done with the downstairs tenant and they
were the ones that told us you were
stealing electricity so they'd accuse me
of lying about it
so dude you got to watch the video they
had they would keep going up and
plugging into the outside outlet and
then they'd run it down in to run like
their fridge and some lighting because
they weren't paying their power bill
that's what sucks about an eviction they
don't have money to pay rent they're not
paying for power they're not paying for
anything can you not cut off your
tenant's power bill even if they aren't
i don't control it
i the city can't yes yeah yeah
so their name is the name on the
utilities
so it just yeah i just got gnarly yeah
i'm looking through the comments here
it's it's uh
it's wild these comes so i like this one
by cat
i used to date a landlord and i used to
be all not all landlords but without
getting into it yes all landlords
oh my god a millionaire smiling to a
camera and saying he's planning to pay
some struggling couple 100 bucks to
allow him to record them in order to
publicly humiliate them is the most
dystopian thing i've ever heard can you
imagine thinking that it's normal and
okay to do
can you uh effing imagine people were
heartless like
crazy and a lot of the stuff it's
because the person that made the video
manipulated it like even that situation
we talked about paying the tenants
to leave so we didn't have to go through
these so it wasn't paying them to get
there yeah it's just it's this is the
one comment that i've had to deal with
something similar um
he almost definitely broke the warranty
of habitability and they were probably
legally entitled to withhold the rent
the water in their kitchen wasn't
working their stuff was open to the
elements for years because of a broken
window if they had access to proper
legal counsel they would never have been
evicted if you find yourself in a
situation like this look up legal
clinics okay blah blah but yeah no i had
a tenant who
was very similar to that would like
break stuff
and then they break out all the windows
right and they haven't paid rent for
three months and you're trying to evict
them and then they're like oh but he
won't fix the windows it's like dude we
just want you to leave like you've
destroyed
well my situation it was uh they claimed
that there was mold but the reason that
they claimed that there was mold was
because they were growing stuff in the
garage with a lot of moisture and they
caused the you know if they're one i
didn't find any but they said there was
yeah so but if if there was i mean that
was their
causing of something that i wouldn't be
uh okay with to begin with so yeah it
just
it's tricky and the thing that
frustrated me is you have all the
evidence of all of this stuff that
they're lying about like we show it in
the video and yet this guy that puts
together the video anything they said he
just leans into 100
and you know you could take
the best human on earth and and
put together a video to make them look
bad and i feel like that's what he did
um
i don't know again the one thing going
back i probably just would have never
posted the video but
do you do you ever think that there's a
there's a balance how could we make this
right between the people who are very
anti-landlord and in in my opinion
that's only growing it's only getting
worse
it's not a group of people that's
dwindling down you know people are
breaking apart it it seems to be growing
stronger and stronger what would you say
to those people and is there a middle
ground do you think to it
i don't know because when you read
through the comments
they truly believe that it should be
just provided and that they the majority
of those people if you read the comments
they don't want to have a job they think
that
human life
should be that you have food housing and
the freedom to do whatever you want all
day every day and that that's just
should be a human right and i think the
thing that's frustrating is it's like no
i think everyone would love that but
who's going to
build the housing who's going to provide
the food who's going do you know what i
mean like government yeah and it's like
yeah but but who because you need
government workers elon musk he's got to
pay his taxes
and then we could build the houses so
the government could do it all so it's
just it's infuriating and it just comes
back to the concept that for
any
system to work
everyone has to bring value to the
system and there are lots of people in
this world that can't bring value and
i'm a big proponent for finding way to
help those people but if everyone thinks
that they can be in a place where they
don't have to bring any value to the
world and it should all be just given to
them that's where we have a problem and
i think
you know it we have to be careful as a
society and not get too far that way
because pretty soon at what point is it
acceptable like i can see you know maybe
there's five to ten percent of our
population that truly needs help and as
good humans we should find a way to help
them but when it gets to the point that
50 of our population needs to be
taken care of by the other 50 percent
like you can't function but how do we
solve or or educate that group
to be able to see a different different
side of things you have them you have
financial education on youtube from
graham stefan
subscribe
[Laughter]
um
it's a great question i don't know
because that's what i think it really
comes down to it's just being able to
get that point across in a way that's uh
because let's be real i mean it's it's
it sells to be like landlords are bad
and uh they're driving up the cost of
housing and then point two examples of
like
uh this person's at with 600 now it's
1200 he's gotta leave
um those stories sell so i think as long
as that narrative continues which it
will because i that that gets people
upset anything that gets people upset is
going to get more views so it makes
sense they're going to continue that
narrative yeah but i think it's only
going to reinforce it like we have a
problem here landlords are bad they're
they're uh they're profiting from that
problem
and uh yeah no i don't know i don't know
how to fix it either so i think two and
this is one point i made in my response
video at some point you have to
recognize that when you lean into that
bandwagon you're really hurting yourself
you're hurting your life you're hurting
other people's lives because
if you are just going to wait for
someone else to solve your problems
unfortunately you're going to live a
life where your problems aren't solved
and it it just sucks because as that
builds momentum that doesn't hurt the
people that are landlords it doesn't i
don't see it ever coming back because
you just have more and more people that
aren't getting access to the things that
i do think they should have but they
just need to work for you know yeah you
know what's interesting uh brandon
bigger pockets brandon turner um mention
me i don't think it was in the podcast
maybe he was in the podcast or it was to
me privately um
he told me i think it was privately that
he offered financial education to the
people in his mobile home parks
and i mentioned something along the
lines of well you know if if you know
isn't that going to get to the point
where for you then they're going to
they're going to leave
and i forget what is i wish i could
remember his response he had such a good
response to that but it was basically
that uh you know if if he offers them
the financial education
then they're not gonna rent then they're
gonna be likely to buy from him and then
he could uh you know and then they'll
own the unit so they'll transition from
a renter to an owner but then in the
process they'll be able to sell them
that and they'll be able to build equity
and and build their wealth and both of
them win i thought that was really
interesting that he provides that uh
he might that must have been privately
to me too yeah that was another oh yeah
uh
man i wish i wish we could have him here
to to clarify this because i'm probably
getting some of this wrong but he also
told me that not a lot of people took
advantage of that yeah well there are
very few people who really consistently
you look if if you really want change
and this is one of the reasons that
i think i love talking about elon musk
but also
i don't feel like i'm even worthy of you
know what i mean like what he's done is
incredible but looking at him
you take something like electric cars
and how the government tried to shove it
down people's throats like you need to
do this because it's gonna be better for
this this this and this and that method
doesn't work but then you have someone
that comes in and says hey this is a
problem
i want to fix it so i'm going to make it
so it's something people want to do not
something we have to force to do
i have to believe there's a solution
there and i really wish all these people
instead of complaining about landlords
we're coming up with solutions that
weren't just you give me housing it's
like all right like
i know there has to be a solution there
i don't know if that education i think
that's a great idea but there has to be
something it would just be cool if these
people instead of complaining we're
actually finding the solution because
the reality is having the government pay
for it isn't a solution that's going to
work
well that's that's the problem though
it's a temporary solution and it does
temporarily work and it does temporarily
make people feel better and so if it's
and especially too you have to think
well at least i think this way if if
someone wants to be elected they have to
appeal to what most people want and if
that's rent control more restriction
more regulation and individuals may be
limited to the you know first five homes
they have to pay an additional tax on
top of that to disincentivize people i
think it's it it's just that's what's
going to be implemented even if it
doesn't fix it long term even if it's
like next five years we'll kind of fix
this but 10 years from now we'll have an
even bigger issue i think most people
wouldn't even think that long yeah so i
just
maybe this is a terrible idea yeah but
it just came to me while you were
talking makes me wonder if the
government right now they've got the
three and a half percent down option
right what if there's some form of
government lease to own option where you
don't need as much of a big down payment
and are the governments a little more
flexible with people in situations like
that to buy
units that would be like too litigious
because imagine suing the government
imagine the building you moved in like
something happens to it yeah
the least owned is a structure that like
benefits the landlord and the tenant
provided by the government so then
instead of money just going to i'm not
saying it's a good idea yeah yeah
something like let's get somebody
creative where there's some way where
the barrier to entry
for housing
is to where it's beneficial for the
landlord and foreign i wouldn't be
surprised if if if at one point um
they're like you know what no money down
50-year mortgage
you know and
they lower the barrier to entry to a
point where basically anyone who wants a
house can buy one if it's available but
by then the prices will have shot yeah
well here's the problem though is then
the risk of this kind of individual now
no longer falls on the landlord maybe it
falls back on banks it falls back on
someone and nobody wants that risk
that's why it sucks that landlords get
the you know you guys suck so it's like
dude do you know we are providing
housing for people that is very
difficult to deal with a lot of the time
you know does that make sense like it
i don't know it's uh what do you think
jack
about what yeah
what do you mean about what
about teddy bears about what part
because you guys are teddy bears what do
you think about a lot of things so about
how you can educate or how you can like
what's making people find the middle
ground
i probably shouldn't spit ball on a
podcast
but i recognize there's a problem i want
people to know that i can see the
problem and i'm trying to be the best
landlord
the only problem i see is that uh that
there there is no solution that's easy i
think the temporary solutions will win
at least over the probably next 10 to 15
years and then it's gonna be more and
more difficult i think the problem's
only going to get worse even though
temporarily people feel like we're
working towards something i think we're
working further away from that i think
the only solution is to probably build
more homes and to lower and to increase
financial literacy increase financial
literacy but but my worry is that uh
financial literacy it's going to be like
some outdated college class of just you
know in high school that kids are going
to not pay attention to because it's
boring
right you know so that that's like i
tuned out everything at school like
nothing to me but i'm sure you would
have listened if there was a course on
personal finance no i had a business
class believe it or not that i thought
was interesting
sucks i loved it i loved that business
class but i tuned out really like and
that was like one of my favorite classes
and i just
and i'm interested in that makes you
wonder if we bring back like
indoctrination you know
where you bring it back you have like
you have like a 15 minute video that you
watch once a month and you're quizzed on
yeah for their whole upbringing because
i feel like they're gonna i think 15
minutes i could teach some principles
that would help people get on their feet
after school i don't know i agree i
think uh as far as like the burden the
burden will always have to be passed on
to someone right and if you're passing
the burden on to someone else whether
that be the government whether that be
uh you know the landlords i think the
only solution is that the burden has to
be upon the individual if they want to
you know find a house or something you
just have to find a way that you can
make them okay with taking on that
burden such as increasing financial
literacy or other i don't know it's hard
but you have to reach a point where like
every problem can be solved by the
government mm-hmm and i'm not
anti-government i think there's
definitely a need for that it just
it can't be the solution for you i
really wanted and i this was an idea i
had uh like probably 10 years ago but
like santa monica was so crowded and
then they had an issue with uh
with getting units and
nobody
very few people wanted to rent their
places because of very strict rent
control regulations there's no land to
build anymore i wanted to build
micro units i'm talking about a place oh
yeah that's the size of this room you
got a bathroom here with a closet just
imagine a little micro unit like this
with a tiny kitchenette in the corner
all you need is like a mini stove a
refrigerator it's enough for like a bed
here put a tv on the wall a micro unit
uh how big is it this is probably
150 square feet so i'm talking like a
200 square foot which is basically uh a
one car garage size 200 square foot
thing that would do so well
and everyone would make a ton of money
from that so for the person renting it
they'll be able to rent the micro unit
for a third of the cost
of renting a full-on
apartment so they're saving two-thirds
of their income
per square foot the owner would make way
more money because now all of a sudden
they're renting the space for like
double what it would normally rent per
square foot but the city can't do that
because it doesn't have the uh amount of
parking they need i think it's per
i don't know there's like a minimum
square footage that they need and then
per that square footage they need a
parking space which doesn't exist so
because of that
can't do it yeah but i would love just a
big building solution a nice building
though not not like a you know like like
a dorm room or anything like that but a
nice building with micro units if
because i'm thinking like if i were like
20 to 25.
i would live there in a second to be
right in the middle to be able to walk
down and like there's all the
restaurants there's all the bars there's
like everyone's hanging out down there
but you got your own spot i always love
that i think it'd be way cool that's
that i think is the solution everyone
wins everyone wins it's true if you
invest in that you make a lot of money
and maybe you'd be able to buy those
units too the price per square foot
could be like uh you know it could be a
thousand dollars a square foot right and
for 150 grand they're getting their own
place right it's a nice view 20 stories
up in the air i wish
i mean yeah
that it would make sense but yeah i
don't think the city would ever approve
that ever but but then you also have to
think well maybe there's a fire hazard
or something like that yeah with with
all i'm sure there's a whole bunch of
other regulations i'm not taking
consideration but yeah the frustrating
part about all of this is any solution
you come up with has some potential
negative that you have to deal with down
the road that's true and just yeah and
maybe it's cramming too many people on a
spot is is a is a hazard if there's an
earthquake a fire a disaster something
happens and there's like a thousand
people and like
authority bill they have slides out the
windows right the solution but there's
yeah so there's gotta be something there
but uh yeah do you have any questions
for us
questions for you i am curious for you
what like what does graham stefan look
like in five years from now no clue no
idea one year from now
i don't know i mean it's definitely
still doing the podcast that's not going
i i i don't know
month by month at this point it's
whatever feels right really yeah wow my
job security feels so good right now
don't worry there there's always going
to be something for alex yeah producing
the podcast yeah
i'm not worried about alex
it's always going to be something have
you guys both liked the transition here
to las vegas
hated it at first love it now it's good
you ain't it i love uh i i've always
liked it though yeah but you're not very
social so like you are you already also
had friends i did not have any friends
and your friend
yes you are my friend but i saw a lot of
you because we lived in the same house
so it was fun those are the days they
missed the good old days i'm very
jealous of all of the creators you guys
get to be around here like yesterday
when you're hanging out with there are
like
dozen youtubers there that are all
like-minded man this is that's cool to
bounce in vegas yeah move here man yeah
it's a good place yeah so that's jack's
room
yeah you want to rent i got two rooms
open i
i'll run it by my wife okay i can't at
this point my house is never going to be
done so it might be worth it to consider
that come to vegas for a year
why wouldn't you we should i i honestly
think i might get to the point where the
three or four months of
snowy wintery not fun idaho um it'd be
worth it just come and live out here for
a couple months because our kids are
young enough we get away with it right
and winters here are much less brutal so
try it out
okay i have another question for you
mm-hmm i'm
what do you think you've seen my channel
you've seen what i've got going on if
you're me what would be your next move
uh probably do a real estate syndicate
probably start building
or a fund because it's like you know
there's so many different finance
creators out there and i think your
strength is real estate
but you've almost tapped out the real
estate audience on youtube it's not that
big i mean really there's i would say a
few hundred thousand people out there
who will consistently watch real estate
content
more people over time that will
subscribe and kind of fall in and out of
there but maybe a hundred and fifty
thousand maybe two hundred thousand
people any given point just like
really into real estate in the us
so i i think from that standpoint
probably a syndicate double down in the
real estate content
probably because otherwise you're going
to get into stuff just to grow the
audience but
like to me you're the real estate guy
yeah um
so i would lean into that i think that's
your strength do you miss being the real
estate guy or do you like the direction
your channel is taking no because
there's there's only so much i could do
i do miss
buying properties but just like if i
look financially at it doesn't make
sense like like anything that i would do
at that point to buy a property would be
at a loss just because you know for that
same amount of time i'd be able to make
other videos that would be way more
profitable so i do miss that aspect of
it though but back then it was like that
was good money to like make a hundred
grand on on you know an equity with a
few months of work but it was just a
grind like every morning i'd be there
every night i'd be there i'd be calling
contract i remember how many times and i
forgot about this until just now but how
many times we show up at 10 a.m nobody's
there
where where the guys
and uh oh yeah they'll be there at 12
blah blah they had to do another project
and i i'm like i'm like all right show
up at three no one was there oh yeah
they're running late they'll work later
tomorrow and they just like show up at
10 a.m the next day then i was like
i can't do that anymore and you could
even hire by the way like the best
people but then
you're you're paying more like yeah then
there goes the margins like on the last
renovation i did i hired a really good
manager like really good top notch but
just the cost went from what should have
been probably 80 grand i think i spent 1
20
because i hired a really great team and
even then it was like 120 and it took
almost double what they but that was
normal but it is what it is you have to
be there you have to be there on site do
you think you're going to buy a lot of
real estate this year though i know we i
want to buy one i want to buy one big
building this year how big uh
i don't know i mean honestly it depends
how much i can make in the first six
months and then whatever that is
will kind of justify whatever the down
payment is because i don't want to cash
out of anything else so like whatever i
make in six months that's my down
payment and
i'll go as big as i can realistically
but i'm thinking maybe like a triple net
something that uh i don't really have to
do much work on yeah that's cool
looking back at your channel yeah what
would you have done differently
i would started earlier and i would have
posted more often
really like how more often just your
throat uh you know what realistically i
besides not starting earlier what i
should have done was gone all in youtube
way earlier
it took me three years it really wasn't
until like 2020 where i really was like
all right i'm not going into the office
anymore like even then i was still doing
like the occasional deal here and there
but i should have i think the after the
first year
i should have just gone all in
makes sense because i'm curious where
the channel would be now had it just
been a hundred percent in that and not
like 60 40. i've thought about that a
lot
that's interesting and do you i know the
last time i was on the podcast you said
like your dream guy to be was dave
ramsey
just because of the way he's done what
he's done is it's still that or do you
see it being i know i'm kind of
re-asking the question from earlier but
is that still the vision or yeah kind of
i don't know why lately i've gotten
really into this headspace of music it's
it's weird
um like you want to create music yeah
he makes songs he makes mixtapes
[Laughter]
that guy is just going to start handing
you his words
dude you're in a great place
i know i know it's it's it's bad because
uh like i'm not good i'm not good at it
like i i know it's pretty good well i
had this idea in my mind of what what i
wanted to sound like and i have no idea
just how to like put my fingers on
because i'm learning logic pro
how to be able to p it's so complicated
the software it's like how to figure out
what i want and how to make it sound
like how i want to in my head and
there's like a bajillion things and i go
through this thing and then i get to a
point where i like i mix the tempo up
where like something auto fills the
entire thing the whole thing is screwed
up and i start over again it's just
learning the softwares
uh which is so it's totally new for me
that makes sense so okay question for
both of you
i've got a lot of questions but
what are the top two to three things
you're both like most proud of
accomplishment-wise like right now
uh jack's definitely buying the house
yeah i'd say buying the house for sure
uh
the main thing for that was like i just
i always dreamt of like buying a house
but to actually go through with it and
go through the process and actually do
it myself i was like oh yeah it's not
gonna happen but i would always talk
about it and i always wanted it but it
actually happened so it's definitely a
pretty big accomplishment uh another one
probably be the iced coffee hour uh
another one would probably
be
mentorship group it'd probably be my
relationships with people i'm pretty
proud of like how i can maintain pretty
solid yeah mentorship group no which is
surprising because you don't text
anybody back
yeah i'm not that great at texting i
don't believe in the the the nice like
formalities and pleasantries that you
share with people i think more so
relationships are built off of like just
always being you know the same like i
can see you a year after i see you now
and we're just like buddy buddy you know
what i mean so i would say those are my
three biggest accomplishments how about
you graham uh
definitely i i i think the channel me
jack
uh
yeah i'd say the channel yeah definitely
the channel making it fun
making personal finance fun i love it
that's it yeah what uh
and then you cut me off and you're sick
of me asking questions but in the last
year life altering
i don't know i feel like everyone hits a
point where
some of the non-like successes but just
views on the world or anything like that
if you had any life-altering things in
the last couple years no i haven't i
just do the same thing every day yeah if
you have any life altering changes
i don't think so maybe
um
i need to have more action so like i
always know what's good for me but
generally speaking i just don't do it so
it's kind of just like quit whining and
just do it so i've been trying to do
that
i would say that's that's the biggest
change that i've made just like do more
and graham's just like dude i'm just
doing right what i need you just gotta
you just gotta do the same thing yeah so
any other things you may want to ask you
gotta
get a chance right now yeah do you have
any questions for me yeah
now
that was a joke my life's not that all
right guys so with that said
what a great way to
spend it there that's a good thank you
guys so much for watching we'll link to
your information down below in the
description make sure to subscribe
like
and get your free stock down below in
the description it's worth all the way
to a thousand dollars thank you guys so
much for watching thank you for coming
on chandler great to see you thanks it's
been a blast thanks guys until next time
oh can i have you look in the camera
really quick we gotta thumbnail really
quick
that's good i do uh like an angrier face